Перший сніг на польсько-білоруському кордоні. Але мігрантів, які застрягли між ЄС та Білоруссю, це зовсім не радує.
Вони намагаються зігрітися у тимчасовому притулку неподалік прикордонного пункту "Брузгі". Їх тут близько двох тисяч.
Ситуація тут складна в основному в моральному плані.
Люди починають розуміти, в яку ситуацію вони потрапили.
Багато хто до в'їзду в Білорусь про цю країну майже нічого не знав, і вони починають зараз усвідомлювати,
що ситуація від них не залежить і що пустили їх сюди не для того, щоб їм допомогти.
Більшість мігрантів відмовляються повертатися на батьківщину, сподіваючись, що їх таки пропустять до ЄС.
Ми не хочемо повертатися до Іраку. Ми хочемо потрапити до Німеччини.
Нас приблизно 50 людей із Сирії. Різниця між нами та іракцями в тому, що нам нема куди, а вони можуть повернутися додому.
У нас у Сирії 10 років точилася війна, там все зруйновано, ми не можемо повернутися додому.
Я не можу повернутися до Сирії, бо там небезпечно.
Можливо, ми там загинемо. Ми біжимо від війни, від вбивств, від насильства.
Ми не повернемось туди, ніколи. Я краще помру тут, нехай мене вб'ють тут.
Це все одно краще, ніж повернутися до Сирії.
Більшість людей прибули до Білорусі з Іраку та Сирії. Але є мігранти і з інших країн.
Так, кубинці потрапляють до Білорусі через Росію, куди їм не потрібна віза.
Як ви сюди потрапили?
Спочатку до Москви, потім хотіли до Польщі, але туди нас не пропустили.
Ми нікому не радимо це робити, це дуже, дуже важкий досвід. Синяки, холод, дощ, голод, одягу немає...
Я знайшов цей одяг у лісі. Це дуже важко, нікому такого не бажаю.
Останніми днями, за даними влади у Варшаві, польські прикордонники запобігли близько 200 спробам нелегального переходу кордону.
При цьому, як стверджують у Польщі, невеликі групи людей намагаються перетнути кордон
у різних місцях під керівництвом білоруських силовиків.
Прем'єр-міністр Польщі назвав кризу на кордоні з Білоруссю "найбільшою спробою дестабілізувати Європу" з часів "холодної" війни.
За останні 40 годин Лукашенко перевіз мігрантів прямо з кордону з Польщею до логістичних центрів за кілька кілометрів від кордону з Латвією.
Це найкраще демонструє, що ці люди є інструментом у руках влади в Мінську.
Моравецький заявив, що Варшава готова сплатити за повернення на батьківщину мігрантів, які застрягли на польсько-білоруському кордоні.
Прем'єр Польщі також пригрозив Мінську подальшим закриттям кордону та перешкоджанням транзитному перевезенню вантажів.
Вже тепер на деяких пунктах переходу білорусько-польського кордону утворилися величезні черги з вантажівок,
що позначається на строках постачання та зростанні цін на товари.
Тим часом Олександр Лукашенко висловив обурення, що Німеччина відмовляється прийняти дві тисячі мігрантів.
Про те, що ФРН пообіцяла організувати такий гуманітарний коридор, минулого тижня заявила прес-служба Олександра Лукашенка.
Напередодні виконувачка обов'язків канцлера Анґела Меркель
двічі спілкувалася з білоруським диктатором по телефону особисто,
чим викликала бурю критики у себе на батьківщині та в ЄС. Берлін вкотре відхилив пропозицію Лукашенка.
Гуманітарний коридор до Німеччини для двох тисяч мігрантів, як ми вже сказали минулого тижня,
як це сказав міністр внутрішніх справ Зеегофер під час свого візиту до Польщі минулого тижня,
це неприйнятне рішення як для Німеччини, так і для ЄС.
Білоруська влада звинуватила ЄС у небажанні допомогти мігрантам і навіть заявила,
що має намір виставити рахунок міжнародним організаціям за їх утримання.
Але піддаватися шантажу Лукашенка не збираються ані в Німеччині, ані в Європі.
У ЄС цю кризу називають "штучно створеною" і сподіваються на швидке повернення мігрантів туди, звідки вони прибули.
Ми вивчаємо можливість проведення технічних переговорів з представництвом ООН
та білоруськими колегами на рівні технічної експертизи, щоб зрозуміти,
як ми можемо допомогти та посприяти репатріації людей, які застрягли у Білорусі, у безпечне місце.
Для багатьох, хто перебуває на польсько-білоруському кордоні, повернутися на батьківщину страшніше за смерть.
Наприклад, для 23-річного Таріка Шафіка з Іраку.
Я боюся тільки одного: що вони відправлять мене назад до моєї країни.
Але дехто все-таки наважується вирушити назад.
Декілька десятків мігрантів вже повернулися додому на спецрейсі до Іраку.
Білоруська влада пообіцяла організувати ще один вивізний рейс.
Втім, за оцінками експертів, зусиль з вивезення мігрантів і тиску Брюсселя на міжнародні авіакомпанії,
які привозили мігрантів до Білорусі, недостатньо для того, щоб подібна ситуація не повторилася знову.
Німеччина та інші країни ЄС пішли недостатньо далеко в санкціях проти Білорусі у зв'язку з кризою на кордоні.
Ми застосували санкції до білоруської авіакомпанії, ми чинили певний тиск на Turkish Airways, щоб вони припинили або скоротили ці рейси.
Зрештою, це допомагає полегшити поточну кризу.
Але проблема в тому, що Лукашенко може будь-коли це повторити.
На мій погляд, потрібні набагато жорсткіші санкції проти Білорусі.
Але чи підуть Німеччина та ЄС на посилення санкцій проти Білорусі? Оглядачі вважають, що це малоймовірно.